Bonjour, curieuses et curieux !
Vous avez sûrement déjà été confrontés
à un problème mathématique sans le savoir
La galère de l'emballage !
Impossible de couvrir parfaitement
une sphère avec une feuille de papier.
Joyeux anniversaire !
Heu.. merci !
Pourtant, dans la nature, beaucoup de plantes
ont des feuilles planes
qui grandissent sous forme de boules.
Et bien des chercheurs de Paris ont trouvé
comment imiter la nature
et déformer un objet plat.
Comme les feuilles de chou en grandissant
les matériaux inventés par
l'équipe de chercheurs de Paris se déforment.
Mais il ne se déforment pas n'importe comment.
L'idée au coeur de leur recherche
c'est d'être capables de programmer la déformation
c'est à dire de construire des matériaux
qui passent de façon contrôlée
d'une forme initiale connue
à une forme finale elle aussi connue.
À l'image des algues vertes unicellulaires
du genre Acetabularia
les chercheurs ont créé des surfaces
qui contiennent un réseau de petits tubes, de canaux.
Ces surfaces sont en élastomère,
un genre de caoutchouc très élastique
et lorsqu'on injecte de l'air sous pression dans les canaux, l'élastomère se déforme.
Ces matériaux peuvent alors s'adapter à une forme,
comme la feuille de chou s'adapte à la
croissance du coeur de la plante.
Et ils ont trouvé un joli nom pour leur invention :
Matériaux baromorphes.
Baro quoi ?
Baromorphes.
Non, barOmorphes avec un O.
Baro, c'est la pression et morphe la forme,
donc qui se forme avec la pression.
L'air pousse sur les parois,
ce qui augmente la taille des canaux
et plus précisément c'est leur diamètre qui augmente
parce que dans la longueur
les tubes ne grandissent pas.
Ainsi on peut savoir exactement
dans quelle direction l'objet va se déformer
mais aussi de combien il va se déformer,
en fonction de la densité des canaux sur la surface
de leur orientation et de la pression qu'on y injecte.
Les chercheurs montrent que pour
n'importe quelle forme en 3d ils peuvent
calculer comment disposer les canaux
sur une surface plane
pour qu'une fois ces canaux remplis d'air,
la surface prennent la forme voulue.
Habile !
Et à partir de là, évidemment,
les chercheurs ont inventé et testé
toutes sortes d'objets, en variant les formes,
l'architecture des canaux
et les types d'élastomère.
Balaise !
Bienvenue dans les tutos de Léontine !
Aujourd'hui, on va apprendre à faire
un baromorphe chez soi.
Pour cela il vous faut :
- une plaque de verre
- deux gobelets, dans lesquels  vous allez préparer un élastomère de silicone
le même matériau utilisé par votre
dentiste pour faire les empreintes de dents.
Coulez l'élastomère
dans le moule du réseau de canaux
que vous aurez préalablement imprimé en 3D.
Etalez également une fine couche d'élastomère
qui servira de couvercle à vos canaux.
Au bout de vingt minutes,
démoulez délicatement le réseau de canaux.
Etalez une couche d'élastomère
pour faire adhérer le couvercle
et mettez en contact les deux parties de votre objet.
Et voilà : un bel objet baromorphe
que vous pourrez gongler, et dégonfler, à votre guise.
Ces objets en matériaux baromorphes
relèvent tous les défis.
Pour la première fois, les chercheurs obtiennent des objets qui se déforment rapidement
de façon totalement réversible
mais surtout des objets qui peuvent prendre
des formes très complexes
puisqu'on peut programmer des déformations suivant plusieurs directions.
Et en plus certains peuvent adopter deux formes différentes
selon la pression envoyés dans les tubes.
Cette recherche pourrait avoir de nombreuses applications, notamment en médecine
et les chercheurs ont d'ailleurs déposé un brevet.
On pourrait imaginer par exemple des robots chirurgicaux souples
qui s'introduisent à travers une toute petite incision
pour opérer ou manipuler délicatement les organes
ou encore des prothèses qui seraient réglables et adaptées aux patients
et aussi pourquoi pas des structures à déployer dans l'espace ?
Et il n'y a qu'un pas pour que ces baromorphes deviennent des matériaux
souples...  populaires.
Qui suis-je
La femme à la tête de chou !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et allez faire un tour sur notre compte Instagram
pour voir les coulisses !